Okay.
Next question.
David.
Should Democrats either slow down or speed
up the impeachment process?
Listen, I think that the timing of impeachment
is just fine and I think that there are bigger
issues about the impeachment and whether it's
going to be politically effective, which for
me is the main consideration.
I still am on the side of impeachment is not
going to remove Donald Trump.
Okay.
Every time I say it, some people email me,
they say, David, you're putting the cart before
the horse or you conceding a loss already
on.
It's possible that impeachment could remove
Donald Trump.
I see it as extraordinarily unlikely.
I see the potential benefits, the political
ones that will damage Trump in the 2020 reelection
campaign that he is very quickly ramping up
so on that basis we've got a slow build going
on right now.
Even with just you know Trump demands due
process and tweets like crazy and then Democrats
put out a proposal and approve it to grant
him due process by officializing and codified
the inquiry and Trump goes crazy again for
some other reason.
Trump is panicking more and more every week
on Twitter which is what you want.
You don't want to just drop everything at
once.
You want to consume Donald Trump from now
until November of 2020 with having to, as
he sees it, fight the impeachment on Twitter
and in the media all the time he spends doing
that is time.
He is not spent just campaigning on issues.
Not that he's much of an issue based guy to
begin with.
It will be a continued build.
He will be tweeting nonsense daily, which
he has been.
Uh, when we get to the public hearings, I
would want to get to the public hearings in
the next month or so and then go full speed
ahead as the democratic primaries get going
in February and onward in 2020 and just continue,
uh, putting in people's mind, not minds, not
only what Donald Trump has done, but continuing
to push him to act in wackier and wackier
ways.
I think that that's all great.
I'm fine also with making the timing politically
advantageous because I believe that the benefit
to be had from the impeachment inquiry is
a political benefit.
I don't think it's actually the removal of
Trump.
I know some people will email me and say,
here's how it could lead to Trump's removal.
I think it is extremely unlikely, so I'm fine
timing it to be damaging politically.
But ultimately what could completely backfire
is if Republicans, if Trumpists if Trump and
the people around him are able to just ignore
the subpoenas successfully and already we
learned this week, a whole bunch of people
who were supposed to show up on Monday simply
weren't showing up.
If they're able to get away with that, they
will successfully weave a counter narrative
that actually could backfire on Democrats
for 2020.
It could make Democrats appear weak.
They couldn't even get people to show up and
the entire thing was bogus anyway.
So the question for me is not the timing.
I think the trajectory is fine.
I think for all of her, her faults, Nancy
Pelosi actually has a pretty good sense of
what the timing should be to build as the
democratic primary and eventually the general
election get going.
I think the make or break is going to be do
Democrats just appear to be totally a weak
flacid, uh, of failures when it comes to actually
getting people to provide documents and show
up because that's what you need.
You need the public hearings, you need the
documents and you need the news that will
build around that already there are question
marks as to whether Democrats are going to
be able to successfully do that question Mark
that hopefully will at some point be answered.
Let me know what you think about the trajectory
of the impeachment inquiry so far.
I think that the timing has been pretty much
spot on.